what's the back story from Bezos and
Amazon well I've met him years ago at a
client Perkins retreat we were both sort
of young CEOs he really came out of a
company started by another friend of
mine Dave Shah a DD Shan company and if
you think about Amazon not as an online
store but begin to think of it as a
trading operation similar to de sha what
Jeff understood was that information is
king even in the retailing business and
that's underlying what he did to to
build he and his robots destroy American
retail no interestingly enough that's
not really going to be the case online
retailing today is only about I think
it's it's seven percent of overall
retailing and it's growing fairly
rapidly at fifteen percent but if you
actually look at how that's going to
track out to the future you happen to
pick an example where I don't think
there's going to be that big an impact I
think it'll probably stabilize at about
twenty five percent online retailing
versus storefront retailing there's
still a lot of value to going down to
that store feeling that Gucci bag and
Jerry also behind those algorithms
there's a huge tremendous human effort
within Amazon picking stock from shelves
putting in a box right and getting it to
you are those jobs gonna go as well
absolutely the futures very bright if
you can afford it and the problem is
most people are not going to be able to
afford it what we're seeing is an
acceleration in automation driven
primarily by advances in artificial
intelligence and over the next decade or
two we're going to see a number of
different lots of areas of employment
just be devastated you know the argument
has always been since since dust copied
Saul was written that you you get new
innovation it displaces some people but
ultimately creates better jobs why is
that not true now that will be true but
the future as they say you we're all
dead in the long run the question is
what's going to happen over the next
thirty or forty years while we go
through a transition eventually people
the people who are out of work may
starve and die and then everything's
going to be great but maybe that's not
such a good thing in terms of our social
policies in the short run yeah so you're
saying it's a one-time transition
and then in the future we'll see other
different kinds of jobs call them job
the labor market chain is constantly
evolving and so it's sort of like global
warming in the sense how what matters is
not that it's changing that's a good
thing because that generates additional
wealth what matters is how fast it
happens if it happens so quickly that
people can't adapt as with global
warming we have Jerry Kaplan with us and
Michael dart of mkm Advisors Israel mica
this goes to a bipolar economy a to
America's economy when you work day to
day in economics is it one America or is
it Jerry Kaplan two Americas of
successful digital labor and people left
behind which is well you you in a
trading environment on Wall Street you
can see you know rapid innovation you
know displacing and disrupting a lot of
the jobs or at least the way that you
know the traders would do their jobs so
I see that firsthand I'd like to ask
Jerry though what would be your one or
two best policy prescriptions for how to
potentially bridge that gap if you have
this period of disruptive innovation
it's a very good question I think the
problem with us looking at this problem
of income inequality today which is
essentially what we're talking about is
that we're looking at it statically
we're not looking at it dynamically so
people are thinking we have to take away
from the rich we have to give to the
poor that's a non-starter in the current
political environment but if you think
of it dynamically the US economy doubles
approximately every 40 years and this
has happened reliably for over 200 years
so think about what that means 40 years
from now there's going to be twice as
much wealth out there as there is today
so the real question used to be the case
Moore's law will have to change recently
because things are changing in
technology well that's true
I think it's a reasonable assumption the
economy is going to continue to grow at
the rates that it has in the past so the
issue is how do you redistribute the new
wealth how do we put the right policies
in place and the answer is to set up
economic system that no longer favors
the currently rich but that permits
other people to join that that let's do
that well I'll give you an example I
have a number of ideas in the book one
of them is to take the corporate tax and
make it progressive so that companies
whose equity is much more widely
distributed
are paying a lower tax rate that's going
to give them an advantage in the
marketplace and therefore companies who
benefit the largest group of people will
will will win I hear that and I say that
sounds like a really good idea and I can
also hear a tax lawyer just licking his
chops in anticipation of digging into
that I want to ask a broader question if
you look at the invention of movable
type right there's this broad sweep of
history we had the Reformation the 30
Years War and then the Enlightenment
where are we on that scale with a I oh
all right well this is a fundamental
change it's gonna sound a little extreme
but this is a little bit more like the
invention of the wheel we're talking
about a fundamental or like the steam
engine maybe that's okay a little better
the point is it can be used so broadly
across so many both manual and
intellectual knowledge worker type
operations it's going to transform labor
that's not to say there won't be new
jobs but the jobs and the skills that
are necessary for those jobs are not the
same sure